in other World News US Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo says he's hopeful
talks between the Afghan government and
the Taliban will begin in the coming
days the US and the Taliban signed an
agreement in Doha on Saturday aimed at
ending the United States longest war
Babu says the US will be watching the
Taliban's next steps to ensure its
carrying out its part of the deal the
agreement set out the conditions that
set out the space but no this deal
doesn't depend upon trusting anyone it
has a deep complex well-thought-out
multi-month negotiated verification
complex and mechanism by which we can
observe and hold every member of the
agreement accountable we'll do that it's
not about trust it's about what happens
on the ground not only yesterday which
was an important day but in the days
that follow that deal appears to have
hit a stumbling block Afghanistan's
President Ashraf Ghani says the
government did not commit to releasing
5,000 Taliban members a prisoner swap
was part of the Accord signed in Qatar
the agreement is meant to pave the way
for the withdrawal of all American and
NATO troops from Afghanistan and a
lasting peace ho dr. Hameed is in Cabo
with more on what President Ghani
Hutchison in less than 24 hours
President Ashraf Ghani went from
praising the agreement signed by the US
and the Taliban in Doha as a stepping
stone towards peace and stability in
Afghanistan
- now saying that he refused certain
aspects of that agreement president
Ghani was specifically referring to the
prisoner swap that is part of that
agreement about 5,000 Taliban held in
Afghan jails versus a thousand afghans
held in taliban jails well President
Ghani said that it's way too soon to
talk about this that he was not part of
that agreement and this is what he had
to say that there was a request
regarding the release of Taliban
prisoners but it can only be part of
negotiations and it cannot be
preconditions for starting the intra
Afghan negotiations also there must be
no issue of goodwill because the Afghan
nation must be assured that whoever is
going to be released will not stand
against it one day
and he says that in the end maybe a good
idea would be to put this peace deal to
the Afghan people in a referendum and
have them decide what question this
country take so certainly these are
words that were not bode well with the
white house would not bode well with us
in voice and as Alma Halil Zac he is due
to come back here to Kabul in the coming
days to try also to bridge the gap
between the politicians here in the
country and - as he had said to ease or
to help in this process of releasing the
detainees